that's it man secret glorious and go was
that I was on GQ I'm Jenna and I'm in
the crib now like everybody these are my
ten essentials look when I'm traveling I
have to bring these things because
legally required to but not everybody
got to handy-dandy passport I can travel
a lot of places with this blue Passport
the u.s. passport but an average on this
passport is very much respected is the
Nigerian passport in West Africa
I get everywhere no feats a nice and
easy baby
so with these two it's kind of like I
got a golden ticket around the world I
do have a privilege I have a surprise
for because I have two nationalities I
am American and I'm Nigerian so I am
African American so I have these two
passports not just for me but to me as a
symbol of my identity of who I am where
I'm from and where I'm going Adonai
essentialist of course I have to have my
Clippers you know
[Music]
as a member of the beer game my beer
tends to get overly it comes all the way
up here to Chewbacca levels and these
are the ones without the cord because
like like right now I got a little a
little bit right here
you're literally good to go wherever I
can
and when you can't do this with a cord
do anything like this
I got cordless mics and I got cordless
Clippers I've had a beard for man maybe
15 years I haven't seen my face in 15
years maybe I need to cut it off to see
a real me i annoy my friends a lot
because one of my essential characters
that live inside this afro is another
guy his name is Chuck Joe baby and as
soon as it gets in me I can't get him
out I can't shake him out it's just a
different posture baby you know and
these are one of the things I need if I
don't have it Who am I gonna be you know
they say be yourself
well I'm everybody so these are the
things that I mean I think it's because
I lived in a lot of different places two
continents two different coasts by the
time I'm 18 different cities and I was
so quiet and shy but I just observe how
people talk I started telling stories as
the people I was referring to I do it
every day like I never spent a day
talking in one voice so it drives people
around me crazy sometimes but you know
when I'm on the road things get dry
shows me dry
the vents can't drive he would gets dry
the skin gets dry and that's what I need
my next essential item none other that's
some fresh shea butter
I'm usually surrounded by wives little
more intelligent beings called women who
suggest that I should get rid of the ash
on my elbows in between my toes
and that's why without its up a shape
it's like shea butter water so after
right now they've been in West Africa
for years I guess it got in the hand is
a Nigerian is it setting the leaves I
gotta say I like Senegal whipped butter
for the record one vital vital
instrument that I need in life it's not
controller even on the game not the Xbox
it's actually batteries the mega pack we
have the mega pack handy and you playing
the game you will never die and that is
the goal of life
I play Call of Duty I playing Fifa wait
a minute okay
I play the barbershop paper and it's
funny because this is the way men
actually relate you know they'd be on
this little headset talking about thing
feelings okay you don't need therapy you
just need an Xbox out of all of my ten
essentials there is one that does not
even need to compete with anyone else
because it knows and everybody else
knows it's number one this is the
essential of all essentials my heart
[Music]
there's people I won't even catch a boat
for I mean friends you know I have to
think twice but my hard drive I will
never think twice this holds the secrets
of my life and this is something that I
love and it is the essential that I hope
never is damaged and I pray the same for
your heart always protect your hard
drives at all cost
and for the record if I pass away give
this is what will be buried with me
another one of my final few essentials
and this one I really love because it's
kind of got that scripture biblical
Quranic look to it it was given to me by
a dear friend and I've been journaling
sensitive so I have a therapist right
now I'm very proud that I'm doing this
but you know she said some things that I
read on Instagram and I wrote it down
talked to my therapist today and she
said talk to yourself like a friend and
then I signed on to ID and there was in
the place a meme that said talk to
yourself like a friend
then I was like I'm not paying it for
she's gonna see this liquid Curtis is
one of my essentials
I'm a big ski lephant house brain is
whatever you got you know your moonshine
version of it I love it growing people
know you sipped acutely you don't take
shots it's killer to go kill them I like
the taste and most of all the feeling of
tequila
like I don't feel too wild I feel like I
can drink a little bit and still get
some work done it doesn't mess up your
teeth like brown liquor which I learned
by drinking too much whiskey another
crucial crucial item I have to have to
keep nice and Popeye strong it's my big
old protein and this one is vegan this
plant-based they're not paying me so I
keep it like this but a lot of y'all if
you know you know that's a slim guy just
gives me them extra pound you little
extra pounds really good protein the
blazing I'm not vegan boxing or
something that I'm started on the last
tour I can't wait to get out there and
spar with somebody right now got a lot
of pent up and it's as if I'm short
something you do so you may be wondering
how do you carry all these essential
things today if you're not wondering it
you should be wondering this is how I do
it with my other essential items none
other than this fancy duffel bag right
here this got the Kente cloth from Ghana
and it's got this wonderful leather that
you can see I got this from a friend of
a friend who came to a show a while I
was in Boston and he showed me this bag
and I thought it was a gift and I was
like oh I like I like this bag this bag
is nice and my and my friend he's I
cannot skin the back give him the back
that's it back and the guy was like no
that's my bag
Union Bank and so he emptied out the
whole bag it takes everything out all
air for all of his essentials and gives
me this duffel bag what a great man I
use this bag almost I use it when I
don't even need it
I would never let anybody borrow this
bag that's not true I'm honestly I'm not
really practicing anything that I've
showed you today it's essential but not
really trippin about these things on
this plane
all right GQ those are my essentials
peace peace get a groove on swag
[Music]